eldon ring is getting some of its
biggest changes yet a new xbox elite
controller could be coming soon and
skyrim gets a fun mod all this on
today's gamespot news
a new patch for elden ring 1.06 is now
live and it brings with it some massive
adjustments previously in the game you
could only put down one summon sign at a
time even leaving an area would be
enough to stop the summon sign from
functioning with this newest patch
players can place multiple summon signs
and invade larger areas this means that
it will be easier to pick up some pvp or
run around the world while waiting to
get summoned for a boss the oft used and
often maligned ash of war bloodstone
step has been nerfed with decreased
distance and fewer invincibility frames
as well as growing less effective with
repeated use another notorious skill
corpse piler now has decreased damage
and blood buildup when hit with the
blood portion of the attack damage
caused by hitting enemies with the blade
itself has only been slightly decreased
other changes make greatswords curved
greatswords and great hammers quicker
and an increased roll distance with a
light equipped load the patch also fixes
dozens of bugs and will now warn players
if they are in possession of an
unauthorized item such as deathbed
smalls aka fears underwear earlier this
year a player ironically named pansu
dealer invaded worlds and left the
cursed item behind for unsuspecting
players to pick up this resulted in tons
of 180 day ban reports from users on
eldon ring subreddit at least now you'll
know ahead of time to toss them because
the ban hammer is dropped the community
response to the patch thus far has been
overwhelmingly positive quote tweets and
comments abound rejoice at the
implemented nerfs and even the buffs to
larger and heavier weapons head to the
link in the description for additional
details on this patch been holding out
for a series 3 xbox elite controller
unfortunately it seems microsoft is
sticking with the series 2 for the time
being as a leak of a white version made
its way online the xbox elite series 2
controller is a premium version of the
standard xbox controller that comes with
customizable thumbsticks and paddles it
has up to 40 hours of battery life and
also includes a charger compatible
carrying case to help make it easier to
travel with the controller which works
on xbox and pc normally sells for 180
the series 2 launched in november 2019
and has so far only been released in a
black version apart from a halo themed
green variant that launched with halo
infinite in 2021. sorry everyone that
loves the new xbox controller's capture
button
doesn't look like the series 3 is coming
anytime soon a great game to pair with
the elite controller is skyrim which
modders have just added the nemesis
system 2. created by modder cyclonics
and directly inspired by shadow of
mordor's iconic system the mod works by
leveling up any enemy that kills you
giving them an extra perk and applying a
debuff to you they'll also run off with
your weapon and the only way to get the
debuff removed and your equipment back
is to hunt down your new best frenemy
the mod does create a quest for you to
track so you won't have to worry about
not being able to find the mud crab that
inflicted a curse on you and made off
with your favorite sword they can run
but they cannot hide you can have up to
five antagonists active at any time each
of which can grow to a maximum of 25
levels above you with the mod using a
respawn system to cleverly keep data on
your foe within skyrim system check out
the link in the description on how to
install the mod
and that is it for today's gamespot news
are you jumping back into elden ring are
you downloading that mod for skyrim are
you gonna buy a sweet sweet new xbox
elite controller let us know in the
comments below and we'll see you here
tomorrow on gamespot